when when you were doing clueless
there's a pretty famous story about you
that um you know you're you're out in la
you're shooting clueless and you're not
a guy who loves la to begin with you you
love new york but the thing that made
you go back to new york was at some
point you got mugged yeah and and and
the dude pulled out a gun and shot it
next to your head yeah so that that you
would you know you would realize he was
for real yeah um that's got to be i mean
i i don't know that i could recover from
that you get like ptsd or whatever well
it was weird because i knew i'd be
getting that exact same thing with
post-traumatic stress after it happened
everything slowed down it was when we
while we were shooting the movie and
yeah a guy put his gun where were you i
was at jerry's deli right in um studio
city
and i went outside to my car and a guy
came out of nowhere put a gun in my head
he was tweaked on something right and i
had no money on me oh and he's thought
like any guy should have said to him i
was in halloween
you're probably [ __ ] your pants
right because you think this could be it
well it's weird i didn't i just got very
calm
and he said you don't think i'm for real
i said no hammy because this is a real
gun you'll think it's a real gun and he
shot it next to your head right next to
my head where like i felt it go through
my hair
and uh
and um
and then i just said look you can go in
my i have a backpack take and he went in
my car
i remember he was like leafing around my
car and i thought i could slam the door
right now on his legs because he was
halfway in my car and halfway out and i
had a split second there where i thought
why don't i just break his legs right
now but he had the gun but he had a gun
and that's what made me not do it but
they don't know did you have any special
martial arts training how are you going
to break somebody's life
sat up and shot me did your hearing get
affected from this bullet being so close
to you
no i remember though it i remember it
being like oh
it that doesn't sound like a gun from
the movies
like it was almost like a pop right it's
much less resonance it's much less
resonant but remember it did kind of
weird me out
uh because then he ran away god oh my
god he could have just killed you yeah
he could have killed me
and then and then i wound up shooting
the the next day i had to work right and
uh
and then
are you the type of guy that tells
everyone on this side you're not gonna
believe what happened to me or did you
are you the strong silent type where you
just kind of go you know if i could i'm
not gonna even bring this one no i'll
tell everybody you tell it i'm the same
yeah
i have trauma i wish that i would you
wouldn't have even made it to work no i
would have had to call in sick you never
guess what happened i almost got shot
last night but then in the same time
frame that you're you're you're uh out
there shooting uh clueless you get the
the mugging and then you have five car
accidents right it was five cars yeah it
was it was weird then the earthquake and
then five car accidents i had never had
anything right where but two of the cars
it was parked i wasn't even in them
um and then hit and run and uh one
hydroplaned and i thought oh i just need
to get out and i came i said i'm gonna
go to new york i don't need to have a
car right so i came here for a couple
weeks and then i got an audition with
i think the manhattan theater club or
something and they said they wanted to
see two monologues
so i uh went and picked out two
monologues and one of them i was i had
done an acting school the other one i
just picked which was amadeus right and
uh which i thought this was stupid it
was a bad decision why am i doing this i
don't know it i couldn't i was sick i
was walking to the audition i'm going
over the lines not paying attention to
where i'm going and i bump into this guy
because i'm looking down at the sidewalk
i go oh sorry and uh and it was tom
hulse who played amadeus in the movie
that's weird and i said this is weird i
was just the reason i didn't i bumped
into use because i was going here going
over the lines and he said oh that's
interesting goes do you live in new york
i said i i don't
uh but i'm thinking about moving here
and he said oh you should it's great and
so i said okay i went did the audition
went back called my landlord and said
i'm gonna move to new york and then a
week later i just i went back packed up
my stuff rented a car it got hit in a
hit and run by god and then at least not
for you it wasn't for me and so then i
left and i've been in new york city ever
since